first one just to get a general idea but
you can notice that on the map
fireflies levels have a firefly in the
bubble
points levels have
diamonds
toys have a little rubber ducky and
later you'll see um
totems levels which start after level 71
have a totem in the bubble so we'll just
go in here real quick and watch the
the opening thing
the fireflies are
they look like that they're
little characters who are trapped in
certain parts of certain boards
um we have to wake them up when we're
playing fireflies level and you do that
by bringing water
to where it's touching them so
it says how to wake up fireflies
you lead the water over their way and
they wake up and
take off
so in this very first level you can see
that we don't have to do anything except
just bring the water down to that one
and he's good
now we need to
do the same thing here because there's
no diamonds or ground blocks around
these two fireflies so this is real
simple
same in the last room so or the second
room
so we'll just go ahead and
free them
and then we just have to get to the last
one we only need to get one
because we've already done that so
we'll free this last one and
that'll complete this level
so that's the that's the most basic easy
way to look at them and how they work
from there
they get a lot more complicated
so we're going to go ahead and move up
to a higher level not super high just so
we can
show you some of the differences
let's look at level
21.
all right so
i didn't really think about this i just
picked one so hopefully it'll be easy to
understand
oh yeah this one is kind of a this is
actually kind of a tough one at times
but what we need to do is we need to get
the water down
and
up to the uh to where he is so
we need to clear out these
raised ground blocks um as best we can
i'm going to go ahead and use this
rocket
because it'll clear out that
space and then you'll see we're kind of
at the mercy of how things fall so i'm
going to work at the bottom
get a shuffle
and we're really just trying to clear
out these spaces on the side
the left side's a little bit easier
because it
you know it's wider it doesn't have this
notch so
that's all we have to do there when we
get them up
so now we'll move on to another one what
i was trying to show you was the alerts
to see how
show you how
to know whether you can move on or not
in a particular level so we might have
to play a couple of them
but um
fireflies are throughout the game so you
know you want to
want to be as familiar with how they
work as you can we'll try this one see
what happens
okay so there's no fireflies in the
first room so we'll just work our way
down
and see where they're at in the second
round
gotta get the water out so
you want to look at the top first and
make sure that you can do that in the
least amount of moves possible
okay so this is what i wanted to show
you you see this exclamation point above
the firefly and it also goes here
what that's telling us is that we can't
move on through this room
without rescuing the firefly
if we do
if we let the water out first then the
level will end right there it doesn't
matter how many moves we have left
but when you see one of these
exclamation points that means you have
to do that first
no matter what
so
this one won't be that hard since we can
match here and now
we have the the path up to the um
firefly already secured so the water
won't go out before it collects
that one so we'll just
get the water out of there
and
see what happens
and it didn't really go that smoothly
but um
hopefully we'll be able to finish the
level with
the small amount of moves we have we
have our booster about ready to go too
so it should be good all right so here
you see there's no exit
this is the last firefly so you won't
see an exclamation point here because
you can't leave the room before
rescuing him
and again like even though we're close
to running out of moves we have this
booster will charge so
just continue to work
and we're going to go ahead and take out
the red
and i hope that we can
we didn't get it
but um you get the idea
so i'm just going to really quickly
play one other one and show you what
happens when you release the water
before the firefly
because i know that's a question that
comes up a lot is how come i have all
these moves left but it tells me the
level is over so
so yeah this level will be good to show
that so
what you need to do is you need to go
down and get to him but
what i'm going to do is
sort of skip that part and show you what
happens
all right so now the water is ready to
go we have 11 moves left but our
exclamations are going off and we
haven't brought water to him yet
so when we make that match over here
it tells us we missed too many fireflies
and that we have to do that to continue
playing the level so
even though we have 10 moves left
doesn't matter there's only
so many fireflies
so
if you skip them as you go along the
level will end so if you see the
exclamation point
always worry about the fireflies first
before you go to the exit
and that's the simple
explanation of how it all works um
there are several difficult very
difficult firefly levels throughout the
game so understanding all the basics
first will help you out
if you get stuck on a level we have
guides and videos for most of them so we
have videos for all but we have guides
for a lot of the hardest ones so
if you don't if you can't find those on
our website diamonddiggersagatips.com
give us a comment here or
in our group our facebook group is the
fastest way to get a hold of us
and just let us know what you need to
help us and we'll try to add it to the
site as soon as possible
if you found the video helpful please
click like and if you have any comments
or additions
leave them below alright thanks